- All of your medical questions
about to be answered right now.
Let's get started.
Huge thanks to Walmart Plus
for sponsoring this video.
Beewoop.
Pam: "Is it bad that I can
clasp my hands behind my back?"
(upbeat music)
No, that's good. That means
you have good range of motion.
In fact, we do this special test
when we check for shoulder mobility
called the Apley Scratch Test
where you reach with both arms.
We mark it off, we see
what your abilities are,
and we can understand which
part of the rotator cuff
or otherwise is impacted causing
your restriction in motion.
Max West: "How much money do you make?"
(upbeat music)
(bell ringing)
Enough to feed Bear for
the rest of his life
(upbeat music)
(scoop taping)
and get him all the toys his
little heart could ever desire.
"Can you develop an allergy later in life,
"or can you get over an allergy
that you were born with?
"I'm allergic to my new cat
"and was wondering if
I'll grow out of it."
It is possible.
Prime example, people
who come to my office
and frequently say they
have a penicillin allergy
and we know we still need
to give them penicillin,
I'll send them to an allergist
and we find out that a huge
percentage, it's over 50%,
have actually grown out
of a penicillin allergy
or never had one to begin with.
So yes, you could
absolutely grow out of them,
and yes, you can absolutely develop them.
Heather Mikulich: "What's
happening when my ears pop?
"Nothing's actually popping, is it?"
What you're probably feeling
is your eustachian tube popping,
which is a very thin tube
that connects your sinuses
to your ear, and that tube
is actually quite small.
So if you have pressure gradients
between your ear and your sinuses,
especially if you're going up elevations,
that popping feeling is
just that eustachian tube
kind of releasing the pressure.
Shin Shen: "Cow's milk, almond
milk, skim milk, whole milk,
"fat free, which milk do
you recommend we drink?"
It depends.
To me, if you're not
over-drinking any of these milks
and you don't have a medical condition,
you're probably fine.
So like drink whichever one you enjoy,
especially in moderation.
Something I will note is like almond milk
doesn't have a lot of nutrition value.
It does have some sodium
content, so just be wary of that.
Cecilia Ann from the Discord:
"What's the deal with a sugar rush?
"Does it really affect kids
and adults differently?"
Sugar rush, made-up thing.
Grandparents used to see
kids eat a lot of sugar
and then be hyper and then
blame it on the sugar.
That is the prime example of
correlation, not causation.
Kids are hyper.
After they eat they stay hyper.
So it's not the sugar making
them hyper, it's their age.
It's the fact that they
have high energy levels,
nothing to do with the sugar.
There is some truth to
sugar causing a crash
because after you eat a lot of sugar
your body has to take
that sugar from your blood
and move it into your cells.
It does that through insulin.
When you get an insulin spike,
you kind of feel a little
sleepy, a little bit drowsy,
a little bit more tired.
A sugar crash is real; a
sugar rush is not real at all.
Renee, Discord: "Why are
some people able to eat a lot
"and never put on weight
"while other people can
put on weight so quickly?"
Metabolism is a big answer here.
Hormonal systems, natural tendencies,
like I'm sitting here
and you can't see my legs
but I'm actually shaking my legs
and it's been proven that
those people who sit there
and shake their legs
actually burn more calories
throughout the day 'cause
it's a process that happens
over a long period of time.
So there's a lot of individual factors
that decide someone's weight.
Factors that we don't think about
and we don't give enough weight to is,
ironic that I said weight
twice, our mental health.
If we're struggling with depression,
we may overeat to
compensate to feel better.
If we're battling with
generalized anxiety disorders
we may undereat because we're so nervous
and not thinking about eating.
Never lose that component.
Grinding Grinding Grinding
Green Grain Grain Grain:
"I keep throwing up every
time I eat prawns, shrimp,
"crab, scallops, oyster, crab, lobsters.
"What do I do?"
Why was crab listed
twice? That's my question.
But then again, you have
grinding three times in your name
so that makes sense.
What should you do?
Don't eat it. I know you're
probably saying like,
"Do you have a shellfish
allergy or something?"
But while possible I can't diagnose you
based off just that little factoid.
What I will say is if you
have true anaphylaxis,
vomiting can be a symptom of anaphylaxis.
I need to know more.
Leana from Discord: "Should
I swap out all white bread,
"rice, grains for brown instead?"
Okay, so the color thing
about the bread is important
to talk about.
If you're a person who's looking to have
more fiber in their diet,
someone who's looking for
better control of their sugar,
meaning less spikes, less crashes,
you're a person that
would probably fare better
by having a whole grain food
instead of a white food.
But at the end of the
day, it's still a carb,
and if you're overeating carbs,
even if they're whole grains,
you still might run into a problem.
So you need to be very careful
when you say this food versus that food
because the question I'll always ask you
right back is, "Why?"
Speaking of nutrition,
you probably know that
my cholesterol is high
and I've been eating really healthy,
so I wanna remind you about my partnership
with Walmart Plus.
You see, a membership from them gives you
free same day delivery of fresh groceries
from your local store.
They've got high quality ingredients
for your everyday cooking, like
organic fruits, vegetables,
or even rotisserie chicken,
which is one of my personal favorites.
With a Walmart Plus membership,
prices are the same as
they are on the shelf.
There are no markups,
which means that you have
access to the same fresh,
high quality food that
you're used to getting
from Walmart at reasonable prices.
It's perfect for everything
from preparing seasonal dishes,
to making a spread on game day,
or even filling in the gaps
when you've unexpectedly
run out of an ingredient.
And believe me, the
selection is excellent,
offering stuff like fresh sweet potatoes
which I like to crisp up in the oven,
or even pumpkin spice, 'cause
come on, it is that season.
And once you place an order,
a specialty trained shopper will handpick
the freshest items.
Organic fruits and
veggies, like these apples,
are picked the day the
delivery, not the day before,
so you could really see
and taste the difference.
They don't just deliver
fresh food products though.
They also deliver a lot of what you need
for your home and family,
like paper towels, beauty products,
and even some sweet apple cider.
Look, when I tell my
patients about the benefits
of a balanced and whole food diet,
I often hear the struggles they have
with the rising cost of
fresh foods, and I get that,
but one of the best parts
about a Walmart Plus membership
is that they offer high
quality, fresh products
at reasonable prices without hidden fees.
Click the link below to get started
with your free trial now.
Latoya: "How come salt on a
slug or something will kill it,
"but I can..."
I have no idea. (chuckles)
How would I know about slugs?
Prime Thyme: "Is it dangerous
to eat too much fruit
"because it's still
contains so much sugar?"
Is it dangerous to consume
fruit because it has sugar?
I would say no because
there's fiber content there,
there's other nutrients there,
and it's really hard
to like eat 30 bananas.
So I think if you have some fruits
and you don't have, you
know, uncontrolled diabetes,
you're fine eating sugar
that comes from plants.
Just stay away from the juices.
'Cause when you have one orange,
that's like, you know,
whatever, 10 grams of sugar.
But then when you make a juice,
you need to put like six oranges in there
to make a cup full.
That's a ton of sugar.
Lalaxuli: "How much water
should I really drink every day?
"Like drinking when you're thirsty
"versus just drinking a
certain number of cups a day."
There is no universal eight
glasses a day, two liters a day.
All that is nonsense.
Those are like averages that
don't mean anything to you
as a human.
Also, something you really,
really have to think about
is it's not just about
consuming cups of water.
When you eat fruit, there's
water intake in there.
You drink tea, there's water in there.
You even drink soda, even
though I'm not a fan,
there's water in there.
You're hydrating yourself.
So you have to take all of
that into consideration.
Then the way that I would tell my patients
to judge whether or not
they're well hydrated
is through their pee.
If your pee is really dark
in color withstanding...
Withstanding? Withoutstanding?
Notwithstanding having a medical illness.
If you're completely healthy
in your urine's dark,
that means you could
use more water intake.
If your urine is clear all the time,
maybe you don't need
to be drinking so much
because you're overdrinking,
'cause the ideal urine
color that you wanna aim for
is like a pale, straw-colored yellow.
And if it's that all the time,
you're doing a great job.
Know that when you're
exercising, especially in heat,
you need more water.
Know that if you have a
fever, you need more water.
Know that if you're just
sitting at home all day,
maybe you don't need as much water
as when you are exercising.
All things to keep in mind.
Inesz: "Can the smell of your sweat
"tell you something about your health?"
It can.
I have actually a whole video on a woman
who can smell certain illnesses.
That goes to show that this nose of ours
is actually not a smell detector.
Well, it is a smell detector,
but it's really a chemical detector.
It can sense certain
compounds in our sweat
that when excreted during illness,
some people are sharp
enough to pick it up.
Dom Lopez: "Why does
Gatorade have so much sugar?
"Is it necessary for the Gatorade to work
"or is it to taste good?"
Gatorade is a sports drink.
It's meant to be consumed
during intense exercise
when two things are happening:
you're burning a ton of calories
and you're sweating a lot.
What do you need to do?
You need to replace those calories
and you need to replace your electrolytes.
Gatorade has both of those
ingredients in there.
When you actively run,
punch, lift weights,
what you're doing is
you're burning the sugar
that is actually in your muscles,
and that sugar needs to be repleted,
and we do so by consuming Gatorade.
Now, if you're a person
just sitting on the couch
playing a video game and
you're drinking Gatorade,
you're essentially taking all
that sugar and just storing it
and not actively using
it, so it can be a source
of unnecessary weight
gain for individuals.
Arex449: "What's better for your health,
"real meat or fake meat?
"If I think they both taste just as good,
"should I eat one over the other?"
Such an individualized question
because it depends on what your goals are,
what you're looking to achieve.
That being said, there is a
myth being propagated right now
stating that all vegan meat
is actually super healthy.
That's not true.
Are there benefits to
eating plant-based meats?
Yeah, absolutely.
Better for the environment,
you're not consuming animal product,
less cholesterol in there.
At the end of the day,
a plant-based burger is still a burger.
There's still a ton of salt
in there, preservatives.
It still technically falls
into the category of junk food.
Don't put it into the
category of health food
because it's not.
Agent Orange 66six: "What are some ways
"for me to stop snoring?"
A, find out why you're snoring.
There's multiple reasons.
B, if you have sleep apnea
and you get diagnosed with it,
you could use a CPAP machine,
which essentially keeps
pressure in your airway,
even when you're relaxed,
in order to prevent it
from collapsing and causing you to wake up
from a lack of breathing.
Mikal: "I'm taking antibiotics.
"Should I eat a probiotic yogurt?"
Si.
- Yes.
- Yes. Da.
- Oui.
- Yes.
- I wish I knew more languages.
You should.
In fact, I tell my patients
that when they are on antibiotics,
that they should either
take a probiotic or yogurt
or kimchi or sauerkraut
because it replaces some
of the good bacteria
that's negatively impacted by
the antibiotics you're taking.
Remember, antibiotics
target only bacteria,
not viruses, not fungi.
But you have bacteria in your body
that actually helps you live,
helps you get nutrition out of food,
lives on your skin
and prevents the
overgrowth of bad bacteria.
When you take antibiotics,
they don't discriminate.
They kill the good stuff
along with the bad stuff.
So you wanna replace the good
stuff by taking a probiotic.
How often should you be showering?
It turns out you might
be showering too much.
Click here to find out.
And again, huge thanks to Walmart Plus
for sponsoring today's video.
Visit the link in the description
to start your free trial now.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)